[Musica]
immaginate di svegliarvi a 400
chilometri da terra non avreste problemi
ad alzarvi probabilmente dormivate già
in piedi se non sul soffitto una
rinfrescata e qui ognuno come può
colazione e siete già pronti per
lavorare senza neanche problemi del
traffico
se ti a bordo della stazione spaziale
internazionale
la stazione spaziale internazionale non
è la prima e non sarà l'unica ma è unica
nel senso che è il frutto della
collaborazione tra agenzia spaziale
americana russa canadese giapponese ed
europea e questo di per sé è già un
successo
ogni
ogni agenzia si è occupata della
costruzione di alcuni moduli e ancora se
ne occupa del mantenimento e
dell'addestramento questo è all'interno
del modulo columbus che il principale
contributo europeo la stazione spaziale
si dice sempre che la stazione spaziale
sia grande come un campo da calcio e
difatti è vero nella intera estensione è
visibile anche da terra con un piccolo
puntino nel cielo quando il cielo è
sereno però lo vedete all'interno degli
spazi pressurizzati sono molto più
angusti ci sono dei sistemi che
permettono al modulo stesso di là di
funzionare ci sono dei sistemi che
permettono di vari esperimenti nella
scienza dei fluidi nella biologia nella
fisiologia umana nuovi materiali e poi
ci sono sempre attrezzature che devono
essere montate al momento dell'utilizzo
in un certo senso una volta che gli
astronauti sono in microgravità sono
l'estensione delle braccia dello
scienziato per fare gli esperimenti ma
ovviamente non possono essere esperti in
tutte queste discipline
e allora buon e procedure supporto da
terra e addestramento sono fondamentali
e come avviene questo addestramento
dipende a chi lo chiedete
l'addestramento degli astronauti può
durare degli anni ci sono delle parti
più teoriche ad esempio sulla chimica
sulla fisiologia proprio nozioni di base
come ritornare a scuola per poi
continuare in sistemi sempre più
specifici su come far funzionare la
sojuz o fare degli esercizi in piscina
per imparare a muovere i primi passi
all all'esterno del modulo solo quando
vengono assegnati alla missione iniziano
la sai mentre nick e è la parte di cui
mi sono occupata io negli ultimi dieci
anni e l'ho fatto da qui da colonia in
germania dove abbiamo il training center
con delle repliche fedeli del modulo
columbus e di tutte le attrezzature che
ci sono al loro interno di fatto come
funziona
abbiamo delle classi dove si fanno delle
parti teoriche in questo caso sto
spiegando l'astronauta che forse
riconoscerete samantha cristoforetti
stiamo ripassando l'anatomia del collo
che servirà in una fase più pratica a
permettere l'astronauta di restituire
un'immagine della giugulare
la giugulare quella vena che permette di
trasportare il di far defluire il sangue
dal cervello fino al cuore
e questo perché perché l'obiettivo
dell'esperimento era di vedere come ci
fossero delle relazioni tra il ristagno
del sangue all'interno del cervello con
delle malattie come ad esempio la la
sclerosi multipla per poter ricreare le
condizioni di microgravità il più
possibile simili abbiamo chiesto
l'astronauta di essere supina e abbiamo
montato l'ecografo sulla testa
dell'astronauta in questo modo abbiamo
ricreato il sistema circolatorio più
simile a quello che poi avrà avuto in
microgravità
a volte il training invece riguarda
delle parti che servono prima di fare
l'esperimento stesso in questo caso
stiamo insegnando come montare le
attrezzature come calibrarle come fare
manutenzione come cambiare dei dei pezzi
questa attrezzatura in particolare ci ha
permesso di fare tanti esperimenti anche
sul sistema respiratorio con dei grossi
benefici a terra per chi soffre di asma
che ha una grande parte della
popolazione ma anche per le future
esplorazioni perché ci sono dei dati
delle missioni apollo che mostrano come
le polveri tossiche della luna
rimanessero attaccate
elettrostaticamente alla tuta e fosse
veramente difficile non portarle
all'interno della cabina
poi ci sono altri esperimenti
sull'atrofia muscolare
in questo caso paolo nespoli si stava
preparando a fare questo esperimento che
ha dei benefici
ovviamente a terra per chiunque possa
avere avuto un incidente può capitare
veramente chiunque ma gli astronauti
anche stando sei mesi in microgravità
non usano gli arti inferiori e quindi
gli impatti se non avessero delle
adeguate contromisure potrebbero essere
veramente importanti se un domani
volessimo andare su marte con la
tecnologia di oggi il viaggio durerebbe
sei mesi
immaginate importante che gli astronauti
arrivino sul pianeta in forma un con in
condizioni fisiche decenti
questo è una carrellata di esempi anche
per farvi vedere come il training degli
astronauti si venga sviluppato attorno
allo allo specifico obiettivo
dell'esperimento quindi quello che
facciamo noi istruttori e di interagire
quegli scienziati di interagire con chi
costruisce le apparecchiature con chi
scrive le procedure e di creare un
prodotto che è la nostra lezione che
permette di dare all'astronauta solo
quello che necessariamente
indispensabile per fare l'esperimento
perché ovviamente di esperimenti poi in
orbita ne devono fare tanti e questo lo
facciamo
seguendo delle specie degli standard
molto specifici che ci vengono dati
dall'agenzia europea
poi una volta che ci si trova davanti
all'astronauta durante il training
bisogna avere anche un pochino di
flessibilità perché non mandiamo di
robot in orbita non mandiamo dei
manichini di fronte noi abbiamo degli
esseri umani
ognuno con la propria personalità e
allora c'è chi arriva in classe che si è
già preparato sulla parte teorica e non
vede l'ora di mettere mano sull'hardware
c'è chi invece più interessato la parte
scientifica e continuerebbe a far
domande per sviscerare l'argomento
e poi c'è anche chi magari ha problemi a
sostenere il jet lag perché dovete
pensare che questi astronauti nella fase
di training continuano a girare
ininterrottamente due settimane in
russia e poi vanno in giusto né poi in
giappone poi torna in europa
ovviamente questo è anche
e faticoso da un punto di vista fisico
ma allora perché c'è tutta questa
infrastruttura di cui tra l'altro il
training è solo una piccola parte perché
c'è chi poi c'è tutto il supporto da
terra ci sono gli ingegneri perché
mandiamo gli astronauti a fare ricerca
così lontano gelo nella stanza perché
perché li mandiamo perché la vista è
bella sicuramente perché fluttuare è
un'esperienza meravigliosa
altrettanto vero la ragione è
principalmente perché c'è la
microgravità la microgravità e quel
singolo ma fondamentale fattore che ci
permette di spingere i limiti della
ricerca ci permette di osservare dei
fenomeni che a terra non sarebbero
osservabili per esempio non c'è la
sedimentazione immaginate di prendere un
bicchiere di mischiare un'emulsione ad
esempio l'acqua e l'olio se li agitate a
terra dopo un po si ri dividono mentre
ingrid in microgravità rimangono più
mischiati oppure il modo in cui viene
trasferito il calore la convezione non
funziona nello stesso modo in
microgravità
quindi questo ci permette di fare
esperimenti ci permette di fare ricerca
di cui a volte non se ne parla
abbastanza le proteine per esempio per
farvi un esempio le proteine hanno una
complessa struttura tridimensionale e le
proteine hanno anche un ruolo importante
in molte malattie
tipo la distrofia muscolare per poterle
studiare il laboratorio serve
ricostruirle in cristalli che sono delle
strutture tridimensionali che più
regolari sono e più è facile studiare
l'integrazione con il medicinale
ecco in microgravità per le ragioni che
ho spiegato prima i cristalli sono più
puri sono più grandi e ci permettono di
studiare meglio le interazioni con i
medicinali e quindi di trovare
delle terapie poi ci sono le stampanti
3d
sarete magari familiari con le stampanti
3d qualcuno magari ce l'ha già a casa
ci sono già sulla stazione spaziale per
la futura esplorazione si può pensare di
usare la stampante 3d per ricostruire
dei componenti che magari devono essere
sostituiti o che sono andati persi ma si
pensa oggi anche di stampare i
medicinali e parlo proprio di pastiglie
perché per le ragioni sempre della
mancanza di sedimentazione stamparono
una pastiglia microgravità permette di
mischiare principi attivi eccipienti in
maniera più omogenea senza
stratificazione quindi questi sono dei
vantaggi per poi non parlare di
spingersi alla produzione dalla sto la
stampa 3d dei tessuti e degli organi un
pochino più avanti e tutto questo ci
potrebbe anche permettere ovviamente di
fare più ricerca e meno utilizzo di cavi
animali ma anche la biologia è un
bellissimo ambito per la per la
microgravità da studiare per fare degli
esperimenti in vitro si mettono
normalmente a terra delle cellule in
vitro e che cosa succede
hanno una struttura bidimensionale in un
certo senso si afflosciano come come
uova al tegamino a meno che non vengono
aiutate con delle strutture in
microgravità invece crescono come delle
sfere e si aggregano tridimensionalmente
in maniera naturale e quindi sono
perfetti per essere studiati e poi ci
sono gli organi di chip
questa è una tecnologia abbastanza nuova
che si pensa di portare in microgravità
perché anche qui ci permetterebbe di
avere degli organi artificiali che anche
anche loro possono ridurre la
il bisogno di sperimentazione sugli
animali e poi potrei continuare le fibre
ottiche vengono vengono prodotte in
maniera più efficiente
ci sono gli studi sulle schiume su
scienza la fisiologia umana ne ho già
parlato tanto ma si studiano anche i
problemi del sonno si si studiano anche
l'effetto del sale nella dieta
quindi la stazione spaziale oggi è
arrivata ad un livello di maturità tale
per cui si sta spingendo oltre lei
stessa nella ricerca e sta allargando la
possibilità ad altre persone di accedere
alla microgravità oggi ci sono le
condizioni per commercializzare la
stazione spaziale ed allargarne
l'accesso a più centri di ricerca ad
esempio abbiamo già questo servizio per
lanciare dei mini satelliti fuori dalla
stazione spaziale
si chiama più si chiama cubesat è già da
tempo e ci permette di raccogliere dei
dati
questo e si chiama invece ice cube è un
servizio che è stato lanciato
recentemente lo stanno testando l'hanno
testato ieri per la prima volta è
possibile oggi per chiunque acquistare
un volume più ridotto anche grazie alla
miniaturizzazione costruire all'interno
l'esperimento in qualsiasi ambito viene
lanciato sulla stazione spaziale
l'astronauta lo installa e da quel
momento il ricercatore o chiunque può
prendere controllo da terra e comandare
il proprio esperimento che da li
riceverà tutte le risorse e il primo
pelo e commerciale ma è un grosso passo
nella direzione della democratizzazione
della ricerca che però non si deve
fermare alla ai centri di ricerca le
scuole e le università
immaginate il vantaggio di avere un neo
laureato che si affaccia al mondo del
lavoro avendo già fatto esperimenti in
microgravità o nelle scuole
oggi in europa si punta molto sulle
stelle le stelle questo acronimo che sta
ma che indica scienze tecnologia
ingegneria e matematica e io ho fatto un
po di interventi nelle scuole e quando
parlo di di microgravità di scienze
microgravità i ragazzi vedo che tengono
l'attenzione è un argomento che ancora
attira ma come si fa a mantenere viva
questa fiamma nel corso degli studi e di
mantenerla prima che abbiano fatto delle
scelte universitarie sia per i ragazzi
ma soprattutto per le ragazze è
importante coinvolgerli in maniera più
attiva loro e gli insegnanti per primi
oggi pensare che una scuola possa
comandare da terra dalla propria classe
un esperimento che è sulla stazione
spaziale non è fantascienza e
tecnicamente fattibile e questo gli
permetterebbe anche di entrare in
contatto con una serie di carriere che
sono un po nascoste dietro ad ogni
missione ma che sono estremamente
affascinanti quindi per concludere lo
spazio di fatto ha sempre affascinato
grandi e piccoli e a mio avviso è
importante continuare ad alimentare
questi sogni ma è soprattutto importante
fornire degli esempi concreti per
realizzarli e credo che oggi la stazione
spaziale possa offrire alcuni di questi
grazie